foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
two billion dollar
that's a really big retirement account
after you leave federal prison like a
really big one
and that's a huge retirement account
post federal prison I'm just saying you
know it is what it is but damn two
billion dollars holy [ __ ]
I think I tweeted this morning I think
all these [ __ ] idiots out there these
dumb [ __ ] that are searching
for Hunter Biden's laptop I think maybe
she should take a couple minutes just a
couple you know I mean you don't want to
get too distracted from the [ __ ] you
know that is Hunter Biden's laptop he
owned a laptop
he owned a [ __ ] can you imagine the
crime that happens when a person owns a
laptop
and then they send emails emails from
that laptop get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ]
take five minutes
five [ __ ] minutes you [ __ ] Hunter
Biden laptop Nazis and figure out figure
out that maybe maybe you should be
searching
for Don Juniors and Jared kushner's
laptop you stupid [ __ ] this is
absolutely ridiculous
obviously obviously the whole narrative
that oh Putin maybe you should find a
three million dollar check he got paid
three million dollars
from a governor or mayor whatever the
[ __ ] it was from Russia and Chinese and
Ukrainian monies and
now [ __ ]
it's a q Anon World we're just living in
it folks holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
two billion dollars Jared Kushner six
months after
Joe Biden takes office
he takes two billion dollars from the
Saudi Crown Prince and like oh no it's
not that the Crown Prince is just
associated with the the deal yeah
exactly it's a [ __ ] dirty deal
with the Saudi Crown Prince
two billion with a B
which reminds me when you talk about
billions of dollars
there's another thing trending
Elon Musk is
[Laughter]
ah he's punked he's punked all these
[ __ ] idiots these Maga types he
punked them
they're like out he bought nine percent
of Twitter three billion three billion
three billion dollars he bought and now
he's gonna let Trump back on Twitter God
damn it
and elon's musk is like no you [ __ ]
idiots I just tried to inflate the price
now I'm gonna sell off and I'm not gonna
be a board member what are you crazy
what are you [ __ ] nuts
and they get punked every time these
people really are [ __ ] dumb they get
tricked into all this [ __ ] all the time
they're tricked into this garbage
they continue they'll never stop it'll
always be the next [ __ ] stupid ass
thing that they believe the next [ __ ]
grift
it always continually every [ __ ] time
we do this it's that stupid cycle I was
talking about last week or the week
before and the week before that the week
before that
that we have to talk about Hunter
Biden's laptop
I should have wrote a tweet this morning
saying Breaking Hunter Biden's laptop to
release a statement on the two billion
dollars it received from a Saudi Prince
you cannot make this [ __ ] [ __ ] up you
can't make this [ __ ] up we have text
messages and emails from Donald Trump Jr
admitting admitting that they lost the
election before the media called it for
Joe Biden and said we lost but by God
we're gonna steal it from him because we
control all the Avenues to steal an
election away from the rightful
presidential president-elect we're going
to steal the election we're going to
undermine the Constitution
yep
it happened
it happened
welcome good morning good Monday morning
everybody we have everyone hears Robin
is here Chris in is here Andrea is here
Debbie from Salt Lake is here
we have Kathy here Caitlyn's here Boris
from Facebook is here hello Forest
uh we have Midas Margie we have BJ from
Facebook Susan from Facebook skip from
Facebook uh Yoda is here uh like Chris
from Facebook Dan from Facebook
everyone's here
I don't see MJ yet
but guys it looks like you guys know MJ
is a favorite here on the show she's
here almost every single day it appears
that she's
a little behind but everyone is wishing
MJ a happy birthday in the in the chat
so let's all let's all wish uh MJ a
happy birthday that one way when she
gets here
and we can sing her happy birthday in
the chat
happy birthday MJ and when she gets here
let me know when she gets here in the
chat so I can um
so I can wish her a happy birthday happy
birthday MJ uh and boy we got a lot of
new listeners from Facebook you guys
know we broadcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
twitch you can go to thetonymichaels.com
and find those links or just search the
Tony Michaels podcast you will find our
YouTube channel go subscribe to the
YouTube channel
and then go over to Twitter and also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod
but we also are coming at you from the
Midas tus Faith Midas Touch Facebook
page
it's uh it's Monday we are coming to you
live every single weekday YouTube
Twitter twitch and now the Midas touch
Facebook page we welcome all the new
listeners you guys get in the chat get
in the chat let's talk
talk to each other talk to me I had an
idea last week if you have a comment or
a question for me put a star in front of
it so I can see it because sometimes I
it's hard to keep track of with Facebook
and YouTube and twitch everyone's
chatting and I don't know if you're
talking to each other to me sometimes
I don't want to get it confused but we
welcome all of you here to the Tony
Michaels podcast
every single weekday for two hours
every one of them Monday through Friday
two two short hours
and we go through the Tweety tweets the
trendy Trends we go through the
important news that you want to hear and
we give you the messaging that you want
to hear that the Democrats and the
Liberals and
sometimes those folks on the left lack
is what we try to provide here on the
Tony Michaels podcast
so
let's get to it and you know the Tweety
tweets and the journey Trends there's a
lot of stuff this morning it was kind of
light a couple hours ago but it really
livened up after a while I mean we'd get
let's see we've got we've got this David
um name it Mamet mimet movement I don't
know who the [ __ ] this guy is yeah he's
a he's a bigot is what he is so we're
gonna um
watch our clip off Fox News from him uh
Andrew Johnson the former the former
President Andrew Johnson is trending
Kmart still exists did you know this
[ __ ]
I saw Kmart 20 trending this morning I'm
like what the [ __ ]
there's three stores left can you
believe that Kmart is still a [ __ ]
thing
what get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] that's not real right
it's got to be some kind of JFK Junior
CRT kind of [ __ ] thing right
we're going to go through the Kmart
thing hopefully we'll get to that it's
not got to do with politics but you know
me I got to make everything about
politics so maybe we'll get to it John
Oliver
uh black males members of Congress
[Laughter]
uh Sweden and Finland
are trying to join NATO so we'll see
we'll we'll maybe have some commentary
on that Herschel Walker is a [ __ ]
that's right Herschel Walker is a scared
little [ __ ]
not surprising he was probably at his
home in Texas that's why he couldn't uh
go to the debate in Georgia where he's
running because he lives in a different
state you know it's it's hard it's hard
sometimes to you know pack your suitcase
and travel halfway across the country in
the state that you're running for the
senate in when you live halfway across
the country it's difficult sometimes I
understand we have Elon Musk
and the trends and also Dr Anthony fauci
is in the trends I don't I'm not sure
why it's probably because
there's a bunch of anti-backsers
and anti-masters that don't realize
that we're this far into covid and most
people have uh you know figured this
[ __ ] out by now
so let's get to I think we're gonna have
um
possibly gonna have Gabe join us today
you guys want Gabe to join us today in
our commentary I really
I really want to get his take on the
John Oliver thing you know Gabe knows
like computers and data and all that I.T
[ __ ] I'm not I'm not uh to speed on that
I'm a boot hey Boomer I'm a you know I'm
one of those I
just not uh just not quite up on that
but
we will see if we can get some
commentary on that so we'll try to go
there we'll try to go there but but the
main story today to me to me the main
story today
is two billion dollars
is a [ __ ] shitload of money let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the Tony
Michaels podcast we have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and the trendy trends
of the day the [ __ ] list Roundup
is there so much stuff
there's so much stuff to round up today
it was a little light this morning I was
surprised but I was like ah we're gonna
get to it
it's going to come it's Monday morning
Monday morning is usually full of
headlines Monday morning is full of [ __ ]
to go through
to take out the trash on Monday mornings
so let's let's just get to the timeline
here let's make this a little bigger so
you can see let it do let's come on
and it's Monday morning what are you
gonna do
what are you gonna do I tweeted Kmart is
still a thing
it's still a thing
Robin says I shop
I love the shop at Kmart where do you go
to Kmart it's my version of Walmart
Unfortunately they close to my area so
there's not one in your area apparently
there's three stores left now three
stores somewhere out I don't know in a
field in New Jersey or something I don't
know I have no [ __ ] clue I didn't
know Karma
Kmart Kmart still existed I had no idea
I thought they were just like a bunch of
[ __ ] empty buildings all over the
country with the K kind of hanging out
half ass hanging off the building you
know what I'm talking about
it's very strange
the Kmart still exists
it's almost
you know this this is how Stuff
um you know you get to believing this
stuff is you go you go through and you
you really you go through life thinking
you know something you know you're
really [ __ ] sure of it
you're so sure of it in fact that when
you hear that what you believe
is not true you get smacked in the face
and you're like whoa what the [ __ ]
that's crazy
maybe I should investigate that and then
you're like oh there are three Kmarts
there are three of them Kmart does still
exist barely hanging on by a thread
but there's evidence of it like there's
evidence of a Kmart existing because
there's [ __ ] three of them
somewhere in New Jersey I believe that's
the story I don't know we're not gonna
go to the thread
I'm just gonna give you the politics of
Kmart
why why Kmart is so important today in
politics
but it's not really the Kmart exist is
the reason why it has to do with with
with politics the reason why this Kmart
story to me has to do with politics and
it has to do
with a mass delusion right and it's not
really delusion that most people didn't
know that Kmart was fully closed most
people in this country if you ask them
for sure are you sure Kmart's gone
there's no more Kmarts they would tell
you yes the same way they would tell you
there's no more Blockbusters
and I think the actual the last one
actually closed there was one store one
blockbuster left
I'm not sure if it's still open or not I
guess we could probably look it up but I
think they closed it
but what I'm trying to tell you is that
yeah sometimes we believe [ __ ] that's
not really true like we believe that
Kmart was gone there were no [ __ ]
Kmarts it didn't exist anymore they went
bankrupt they closed them all the one in
my Town's closed the one in this town
that I go to over here that one's closed
I my my my relatives in this town said
their Kmart's closed Kmart is done
it's not done
I mean factually that's untrue there's
three of them what's four I guess they
just closed one
here's the point
the point is is that when you get
evidence right when you receive evidence
that there's three Kmarts you're like oh
okay well maybe there is still Kmart you
know like I guess so it's not closed yet
I was unaware I was unaware man
but then when you receive the evidence
right
or the lack thereof of evidence
then you would you would [ __ ] you
would know
what the truth is and then you would be
like oh okay well you know
Kmart does exist okay sure
but when you live in our country today
the way that we process information we
process facts or what should be facts
we could say car Kmart does not [ __ ]
exist it does not exist that's all
that's all the [ __ ] rules that's part
of the the Deep State narrative that
Kmart still exists they want you to
believe that Kmart still exists
that way they can fight they can fight
against Walmart the superhero of all
marks
you have Kmart and then you have Walmart
and Walmart is the superhero of all the
marts
I don't know
but you see how this delusion exists
it doesn't mean that you're you know
willfully delusional
I didn't know I had no clue that there
were still Kmart no [ __ ] idea though
this morning
I was today years old when I found out
there's still a couple Kmarts running
around out there somewhere
the point is this
it's the same way that these [ __ ]
people believe that JFK Jr is going to
come back
it's the same way that these people
think that the election was stolen
but the difference is when they're
provided facts when they're provided
evidence or the lack thereof
they completely dig in they completely
dig in
nope Kmart does not exist
there's not one [ __ ] Kmart open in
this entire country that's what it would
be like if I came on the show this
morning
and I made a real hard case of why
Kmart's not really open and it's just
it's just a [ __ ] deep State cabal
narrative to get you to believe that
Kmart's still open so that way so that
way you don't go to the Walmart which is
the which is the good the good Mark
which they want to boycott Walmart too
but
it's not the point the point is
that that's part of the delusion
is the propaganda that is coupled with
the lie or the untruth
because the truth of it is is that
Kmart's not going to exist very much
longer and it's not it's just not
probably
the untruth is is that it's completely
gone
we learned that this morning through the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends did
you like how I made do you like I make
Kmart political oh my God
talk about a [ __ ] stretch
talk about a [ __ ] stretch Tony okay
uh yesterday I did an interview with bad
Brad Burke what you know Bad Brad is a
friend to the show and a friend to the
fight
to move Humanity forward as he always
says so go check out Bad Brad Berkowitz
Channel over on YouTube and you can
watch the interview we had a good chat
yesterday
uh so go check that out on Bad Brad
berkwich YouTube channel
don't forget the subscriber over there
he does a lot of really really really
good 360 interviews as he calls them
it depths in-depth interviews and
they're all right there uh our co-host
and executive producer Gabe Sanchez did
one with him a couple weeks ago so while
you're over there watching the interview
with me check out the one with Gabe as
well it's right there on the channel
it's right there okay let's see oh
here's another important story I think
this is probably the most important
story today
in politics other than like the Liz
Janie story which we'll get to the clip
of Liz Cheney here in a bit
but I said while you dumb [ __ ]
are out there searching for laptops you
might want to grab kushners
this is really [ __ ] stupid folks that
they're still talking about Hunter Biden
owned a [ __ ] laptop right
am I the only one that thinks this is
dumb
that they think it's criminal to own a
laptop they're like no 100 Bands laptop
does exist
the laptop exists no one questioned
rather he owned a laptop
I mean I'm sure Hunter Biden owned a
[ __ ] ton of laptops
I mean I've had a lot of laptops in my
life they're normally they're [ __ ]
junk like normally they suck you know
you have them for a couple years the
battery goes bad it costs more [ __ ]
money to buy a new cord or a new battery
then just get a new [ __ ] laptop
what is the big [ __ ] deal about
someone owning a goddamn laptop I am not
[ __ ] figure that [ __ ] out yet
and then they're like oh he emailed from
the lab what the [ __ ] yeah sometimes
sometimes when you own a laptop
you email from it
like you write documents you email you
search the web you might even look at
porn I mean Josh Holly can you imagine
Josh Holly's [ __ ] laptop history on
that dude
oh but he doesn't own a laptop because
he's a conservative conservatives don't
own laptops laptops are bad liberal deep
State devices they're the machines that
stole the election what the [ __ ] why is
it so [ __ ] weird
that people own laptops do these people
not know what a laptop is
I'm [ __ ] serious do they not know
what a laptop is
it's a legitimate question at this point
because they're completely obsessed
about it I don't even think they know
what a laptop is over at Fox News and
they have no [ __ ] clue
like can you imagine own a laptop
an email one from that [ __ ]
Jesus [ __ ] crashed
how Criminal
I mean you can commit crimes on a cell
phone and commit crimes on a laptop a
desktop computer
[ __ ] you can commit crimes through the
mail the snail mail
the effective fax machine for crying out
loud
half the people in this country don't
even know what the [ __ ] a fax machine is
anymore what are you people talking
about
he owned one he had one it's [ __ ]
real 100 Button had a laptop
all the while Jared Kushner
is doing a two billion dollar deal I
wonder I wonder I wonder if they're
trying to distract
the maggots out there the Trump humping
idiots
these these [ __ ] let's go Brandon
Nazis you know I'm talking about
you know what I'm talking about your
your neighbor down the street Daryl you
know he's got the [ __ ] old ass pickup
truck with all the [ __ ] shitty ass
Trump bumper stickers on it
he's got a Confederate flag on one side
the American flag on the other because
he has no [ __ ] clue who fought in the
Civil War and who fought against who in
the Civil War no [ __ ] clue which
we're going to talk about today because
Andrew Johnson is trending
what the [ __ ]
it's absolutely ridiculous
it's craziness
craziness
that they have distracted these [ __ ]
morons
about a laptop
from the Trump children
benefiting from a two billion dollar
deal
from the Saudi Prince
I wonder I wonder if Jared Kushner did
it through email
I wonder okay let's get back to to the
timeline here um here is the uh
here's the the clip of Liz Cheney that
everyone's talking about
um I tweeted this morning and you'll
know what I mean by this once you see
the clip trumpism has made Liz Cheney
its mortal enemy this is a really dumb
thing that they're doing
that Trump and trumpism is making Darth
Vader Jr their enemy this these
[ __ ] will take you hunting
under the guys that yeah we're friends
we're gonna go bird hunting and shoot
you in the [ __ ] face
I mean I don't know if that's
intentional I mean it's the story but
you know it's salacious so we're gonna
say it here I don't give a [ __ ] but
think about it think about it
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is this is the [ __ ]
that they want to do they want to make
Darth Vader and Darth Vader Jr their
enemies and if you don't believe me you
just go back and you look at the one
year anniversary of January 6.
and who were the two Republicans only
two Republicans one was a sitting
congresswoman which is Liz Cheney and
her father Darth Vader were there in
solidarity with Nancy Pelosi to
commemorate
and to to mourn the January 6th
insurrection
and give it attention Darth Vader stood
there arm and arm with Nancy Pelosi
think about that for a second just put
that in your [ __ ] mind for a second
now Liz Cheney and Dick Cheney are no
friends to democracy everyone [ __ ]
does that [ __ ] oh they're great and this
and that and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and I'll fight anyone you know not
physically I mean you know maybe I'll
box with him but in a ring
but I'll go Toe to Toe with someone who
wants to argue with me that Liz Cheney
is some kind of [ __ ] hero to
democracy she's not
don't get it [ __ ] twisted this is the
same person who's voted against voting
rights just this year
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
she loves democracy get out of here [ __ ]
that
but I said this election cycle is going
to be one for the history books
and the reason why is because if anyone
thinks
that that Darth Vader and Darth Vader Jr
is going to just give up let's see here
we go and we'll get this clip going
they're just gonna give up
and they're not going to fight for their
party because that's really Liz Cheney's
fight here this Cheney isn't fighting
for democracy
she's fighting for her style of fascism
right
come on
she's fighting for her style of fascism
which is the old you know the old guard
the old GOP
you know where they thin veiled it with
conservatism and debts and deficits and
tax cuts for the rich
I mean that you know that's the [ __ ]
that they thin veiled their fascism with
it's still fascism but it's not you know
they weren't saying the quiet part out
loud that's a [ __ ] that pisses the
Cheney's off because like Jesus Christ
you're making them know that we're Nazis
for crying out loud but let's listen to
Liz Cheney Dr Jake Tapper about how
she's gonna [ __ ] bury these
[ __ ] if you're the vice chair
of the January 6th Committee of the New
York Times uh reporting this morning
that your committee has concluded that
you have enough evidence to make a
criminal referral for president Trump to
the justice department for obstructing
an official proceeding and for
conspiracy to defraud the United States
um is that true do you have enough
evidence to refer Trump for criminal
charges well we have not made a decision
about referrals on the committee I think
that it is absolutely the case it's
absolutely clear so I think this is
important
um and I think I may bring KFA back on
this week to talk about this clip
because we kind of talked about this
last week with Karen agnipolo a legal AF
we talked about why January 6th select
committee may or may not give criminal
referrals and how that would affect
any prosecutions and Karen's case was
well they don't need to really make
referrals like it doesn't that's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] stuff that that
Lawrence tribe and to be honest with you
Don Winslow is trying to sell you
they're trying to sell you
a line of [ __ ] that that somehow the
January 6th select committee has to make
a criminal referral if a crime is
committed listen if the doj knows about
crimes committed they don't need a
referral from Congress to [ __ ] indict
somebody
they don't need they don't need a
referral if they know about that crime
being committed
okay got it you follow they don't need a
referral if doj already knows that crime
is committed
they don't need one
now what Liz Cheney is doing here I
believe what she is doing here and I'm
going to ask Karen this week maybe
tomorrow Wednesday
I believe what Liz Cheney's doing here
is projecting to doj that hey we got
what you got we think it's criminal but
we're not we may or may not give you a
criminal referral wink wink she's doing
the old wink wink thing right we may or
may not do a criminal referral but if we
want to then we will and here's here's
let's let's listen here that
um what president Trump uh was doing uh
what what a number of people around him
were doing that they knew it was
unlawful they did it anyway I think you
certainly saw that in the decision uh
that was issued by judge Carter a few
weeks ago uh where he concluded that uh
it was more likely than not that the
president of the United States was
engaged uh uh in criminal activity now
this is very important now what she's
talking about is but judge Carter out of
California who ruled on the Eastman
emails the emails emails emails
emails it enters the [ __ ] January 6th
Insurrection the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup chat
now why is this important the reason why
it's important is because the doj does
not have a former event to go to to see
how to prosecute the a president of the
United States
Liz Cheney knows that
and a lot of others on the January 6
select committee know that
Merrick Garland knows that
I'm sure the United States Attorney
federal attorney in the southern
district of York and in D.C and in
Georgia know that
well how do we prosecute a former
president United States well judge
Carter lays it out
in that [ __ ] decision he tells you
why and how you should prosecute a
former president of the United States
it's pretty easy
it's like a road map right why is all
this important well the reason why it's
important is because the Department of
Justice Just got a plea deal from a
proud boy uh his name is Donahoe from
New York I believe I did correct me if
I'm wrong on that but his name is
Donahoe he's one of The Proud boy
leaders he's one of Enrique Tarios
lieutenants
and this is very [ __ ] important and
listen to me
listen to me when I say I am not a
lawyer
but
when they're charging these
[ __ ] with conspiracy
and specifically conspiracy to obstruct
an official proceeding that was count
one
that Donahoe
pled to was conspiracy
to obstruct
an official proceeding it's very
important and the reason why it's so
[ __ ] important
is because
that is what judge Carter the judge that
Liz Cheney is talking about here lays
out the crime
that Eastman and Donald Trump committed
which was they knowingly and criminally
obstructed an official proceeding
so here we have a judge in California
that makes a decision
laying out how to prosecute a former
president of the United States
for obstruction of official proceeding
and allows the January 6th select
committee to get those emails and to get
that evidence and by the way if you
think that the January 6 elect committee
can get it and Department of Justice
can't you're fooling yourself
foreign
is standing here telling you telling you
out loud
that Carter's decision in California is
the charges that are going to be brought
in so many [ __ ] words
think about it
if there's a conspiracy with The Oath
Keepers with the proud boys
if they were in communication with I
don't know maybe a guy named Roger Stone
maybe a guy named Steve Bannon you know
two guys who were pardoned by the
president of the United States Donald
Trump at that time
listen if you don't see
if you don't see the connections here if
you don't see how this is going to lay
out
not just not just criminally with
indictments because I I believe they're
coming
I believe they're coming
and I think Liz Cheney in the January
6th select committee one of their jobs
is to let the American people know
what the story is
right that's the most important part
about the January 6 select committee
other than they need to change a few
things about our system
so that way we can make sure that some
buffoon doesn't try to overthrow our
government again
and commit a Cheeto dusk kangaroo coup
with something particularly like an
Eastman memo that would lay it out
but we have
we have right in front of us our eyes
the facts
a proud boy Donahue who is a who is a
lieutenant to Enrique tario
who met with Stuart Rhodes who is who is
the [ __ ] Oath Keepers founder who had
the orders with the qrf the weapons that
were stored across the Potomac meeting
on January 5th
we have Roger Stone being protected by
the proud boys and the day of January 6.
an oath keeper who has pled guilty
telling you folks
Miss Eastman memo this decision from the
judge in California what Liz Cheney's
talking about here is very [ __ ]
significant
may not seeming in the moment it may
seem like well they're not really going
to do anything they haven't done
anything yet but they're not lit
they've got almost 800 indictments
criminal indictments there's people
right now as we speak sitting in a
federal prison with their cold feet on a
concrete floor
and Liz Cheney is telling you out loud
how to kill trumpism because that's what
she wants to do ultimately that's her
goal
is to tear down trumpism so she can take
her party back
she's laying it out for you she's
telling you she's projecting it to you
this is how judge Carter's decision
that's how
we may not give a criminal referral
because they don't have to
they don't have to
very important let's finish see what
else she says it's not quite as
important but let's listen uh I think
what we have seen is a massive and well
organized and well-planned effort that
used multiple tools to try to overturn
an election uh you've seen just in the
last few days uh a plea agreement from
one of the leaders of The Proud boys
which which lays out and really chilling
detail the extent to which violence was
planned
um the extent to which uh the message
that went out on December 19th about the
planning about the rally for Washington
and don't forget Donald Trump tweeted
out that message be be there be wild
um that the day after that message uh
the organization and the planning
started and and that they understood
that they knew that they were going to
attempt to use violence to try to stop
the transfer of power that is the the
definition of an Insurrection it's a
conspiracy she's saying without saying
the working Spirit see she's telling you
it's a conspiracy and I wish I wish all
the best of luck to the enemies of Liz
Cheney out there because uh you have to
identify your enemy first
um and a lot of people think again that
she's on the side of democracy and uh
she she may appear to be because she's
trying to tear down trumpism which is
right now is the enemy of our democracy
trumpism fascism in a Maga hat is the
enemy of our democracy it is
that's that's what they're trying to do
is destroy our country destroy our
constitution destroy our Liberty
I mean you can see it all around the the
United States as they're trying to pass
bills so they can legally marry children
they can they can ostracize people from
society and strip away their Liberty
rather they have a uterus or they have a
certain person they love of the same
gender
they're continuing the scourge for our
children and for us
they don't believe for a second that she
is pro-democracy she's just anti-trump
and sometimes
the enemy of your enemy
can help you out so I'm not against
letting Darth Vader Jr here destroy
trumpism
let's do that Mayo makes a very good
point here just because Liz Cheney hates
Donald Trump doesn't mean I trust her
it's a good point Mayo thank you very
much
again a very very good point dip the
food
let's see
oh Gabe post about Elon Musk earlier uh
I think this was last night he says um
and just like that maga's delusion
delusional hopes and dreams for Twitter
just went up in smoke uh you see Madison
Gotham here reinstate Trump
let's see this is from Marjorie Taylor
green will the new majority shareholder
return freedom of speech to Twitter
it will require courage because the
regime is heavily invested
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Twitter CEO says Elon Musk decided not
to join the company's board
really pissed in their Cheerios
hardcore pissed in their Cheerios what a
bunch of dumb [ __ ]
Elon Musk Punk and magas is I'm not a
fan of Elon Musk [ __ ] that guy but I
like when he punks when he punks
manga okay let's hear it
here's the story Gabe's got it here uh
no please tell me how Hunter Biden's
laptop is a problem
and not Jared Kushner getting two
billion I'll wait
here's the story that he tags to you for
the New York Times go check that out
uh we'll talk a little bit more about
that if Gabe joins us let's see is he is
he gonna
she's gonna jump in here let's see let's
see if I got a message no
I don't know folks you may be sorely
disappointed today it doesn't seem that
Gabe Sanchez our co-host and executive
producer
may or may not be joining us he's
probably very busy making all his great
videos so calm down there's probably
videos that are going to be released
okay
oh again check out the interview with
bad Brad Burkwood
on the show oh here we go
here's a good video
of a dumb [ __ ] uh Joe says to think the
adult spawn of the cousin marrying butt
dialing
compressor next to the dildo store
holding lie down on the bed shirt
tucking hair dye leaking airport shaving
coveted via fart spreading apart from
New York law practicing former mayor is
just as bat chick crazy as his dad
um so Ron posted this video and of
course this is on Newsmax Newsmax
fantastic
this is Andrew Giuliani let's listen to
this nonsense for a second Aaron
parents your child they have a private
the way they see
Kansas is doing here in Florida and I
would push legislation like that in New
York and I look forward to signing into
law next year so he's a [ __ ] bigot
huh who'da guessed it who'da guessed it
that he's a [ __ ] bigot Ron says
Andrew Giuliani says
when he gets elected governor
that's a funny that's a funny sentence
that's funny Andrew Giuliani says when
he gets elected governor
come on in there come on I just kind of
[ __ ] funny right you can't hardly
write a better joke than that Andrew
Giuliani says when he is elected
governor
he will introduce a don't say gay bill
they want to introduce this all around
the country I'm sure Andrew Giuliani
will also introduce a bill wanting to
marry children
I mean they're introducing in Tennessee
Missouri I'm sure Florida is right
around the corner Texas will try to out
Florida Florida they'll have a they'll
have a married kid bill I mean how else
are you going to educate children other
than the Miriam
God damn you got to marry him really
young that way you can groom them up
teach them how to be a [ __ ] fascist
[ __ ] idiots
these [ __ ] idiots
it really is ridiculous okay
thanks for your Tweet
and the video Ron okay let's go back oh
we gotta give Joe credit too see if you
read it you give credit we give credit
here on the show
when we read a tweet and there we go
oh this is a great picture that's been
circulating around I called it the
Cheeto dusk Confederacy uh Rachel
bickoffer a friend of the show she says
GOP releases their 2022 platform
see this [ __ ] Flag this is
they're giving away they're giving away
what they mean here so when you see when
you see the back of a truck and it's got
an American flag and a Confederate flag
you know one next to the other
now this is what they mean they want the
United States to go back to the
Confederacy where they can own slaves
that's what they that's what they want
to go back to
that's how they want to own black people
is what they're saying
I mean it's a it's a white hand
and that's what they're saying when they
have a Confederate flag and and they
haven't and they have an American flag
right next to it
it really is
ridiculous okay thank you Rachel for
pointing out that that's their 2022
platform
they want to take us back to the Cheeto
dust Confederacy they want to own black
people folks
how simple can it get
okay let's go to the let's go to do the
uh treaty tweets and the trendy Trends
let's go to the trends see if we get an
answer and our executive producer here
and it goes it's still no answer
trending
let's see what do we have
oh this David David name it then he said
name it Mammoth movement I don't know
this [ __ ] guy uh he was on Fox news I
guess
um he was on Fox News
talking some bigoted ass [ __ ] I don't
know who this guy is do you know who
this guy is he writes plays or something
why we give a [ __ ] what this bigot says
but let's listen but we have to take
back control if there's no community
control of the schools uh what we have
is
um kids being not only indoctrinated but
but groomed in a very real sense here's
that [ __ ] word again there's that
[ __ ] word again groomed this is this
is the nonsense and the [ __ ] that
they're trying to spread the propaganda
that they're trying to [ __ ] spread
they're trying to say that they're going
to turn your kids gay
that's that's what he's saying
when he says that [ __ ] he's like gay
people bad and they're trying to turn
your kids gay that's what he's saying
that's the code words
doubt me
that's that's the that's the [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] thing he's saying
gay people bad they're trying to turn
your kids gay
why people who are yeah whether they
know it or not sexual predators
they know it or not they're sick rather
gay people know it or not they're
they're who they love who they love and
want to be with
and want to want to have a partnership
in life
rather they know it or not that's
predatory sexually what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
this is this is what I've been saying
for [ __ ] weeks here is that they're
trying to [ __ ] sexualize
they're trying to sexualize
our kids gender
and the reason why they want to
sexualize our kids gender is because
they want to scare you into believing
that gay people bad and gay people are
sexual predators and they want to groom
your children to believe that [ __ ]
here's what they're terrified of folks
they're terrified of the truth and
they're terrified they're terrified that
children all around this country are
discovering
the truth
that that lgbtq community members are
are not
inhuman they have Humanity they're human
beings they have feelings they have
relationships they have thoughts they're
not perfect
some are artistic some are athletic
some some you don't even know that
they're members of that Community until
you would actually I don't know sit down
and [ __ ] talk to them
foreign
but here you have this [ __ ] here
saying that gay people rather they know
it or not LGBT community members rather
they know it or not are sexual predators
what a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know who this guy is I don't
know and I don't really give a [ __ ] who
he is the point is he's on Mark Levin's
show on Fox News and he's indoctrinating
your [ __ ] parents
into believing that gay people are
grooming children
and that gay people are are [ __ ]
sexual predators rather they know it or
not
I get to dictate
I get to dictate who the sexual
predators are because it's definitely
not me
that's what he's saying
you don't think this is [ __ ]
projection from this [ __ ] sick son of
a [ __ ]
I would say so abusing the kids uh
physically no I don't think so but
they're abusing them mentally and use
and using um sex to do so this has
always been the problem with education
see this is the other [ __ ] stupid ass
thing that they say because they're not
just coming they're not is coming for
your children's Minds folks are coming
for their bodies that's what that's the
projection here is they're not just come
oh oh well it's not just a physical
thing I mean Jesus Christ Republicans
want to marry children in Tennessee they
want to marry children in Missouri
they want to sexualize your kids gender
in Texas and Florida and now New York if
Andrew Giuliani becomes governor
say that sentence no that's [ __ ]
ridiculous
but they're coming not just for your
children's Minds these fascists are
coming for their bodies they want to
marry them they want to make sure what
their genitalia is and they get to check
it when they go in the bathrooms they're
[ __ ] weirdos these fascists are
[ __ ] weirdos and they're obsessed
obsessed with your children's genitalia
and wanting to marry your children's
genitalia they are obsessed with it
because the teachers are inclined
particularly men because men are
predators to a pedophilia and that's why
there were strict
um Community strictures about it
thank God so this started to break down
when the schools said you know what we
have to teach the kids about sex why
because what if they don't do it at home
this is really [ __ ] stupid the
schools are not teaching your children
about sex
they're not they're not teaching
kindergartners about sex the Republicans
are are telling people who aren't
involved in schools because they're dumb
[ __ ]
the people who you remember remember
last summer
when we watch video after video after
video after video of these dumb
[ __ ] yelling and screaming into
a microphone at a school board meeting
all kinds of queuing on crazy [ __ ] about
CRT and and and the [ __ ] the cabal
and the Deep State and vaccines and math
all kinds of crazy ass whack you do [ __ ]
those people who were screaming in the
microphones at school board means either
a either a we're not in that school
district
they were running around all over the
country in different school districts
posing as parents or B they are parents
in that District that don't [ __ ]
participate in their children's
education
because if they did if those parents
were actually involved and engaged in
their children's education they would
understand that CRT is a bunch of
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] Voodoo it's
[ __ ] propaganda that the fascists are
trying to convince you that they're
trying to make your white children feel
guilty it doesn't exist you dumb
[ __ ]
the other thing that they would realize
if they would pay the [ __ ] attention to
their students education their
children's education engage in their
local school is they would realize they
don't teach kindergartners
first graders second graders about sex
they don't do that
that's a thing that Republicans are
making up to pass laws to ostracize and
demonize gay children lgbtq children and
their lgbtq parents
what about the Texas law is so [ __ ]
is so [ __ ] complicated
they want to make sure they can
criminalize
lgbtq parents in Texas
that's what they want to do that's what
they're working towards they start with
the children they work to the parents
they criminalize them they put them in
jail Jesus Christ they're gonna try a
woman in Texas for the murder
of a human because she had a medical
procedure
you heard this
it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] folks all of
it and [ __ ] this guy whoever this guy is
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
and [ __ ] Mark Levin and Fox news for
Aaron that [ __ ] garbage lies and
hatred and bigotry
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay let's move on to uh Andrew Jacks
Johnson excuse me Andrew Jack Andrew
Johnson
uh is training he's a former President
Andrew Johnson
was the Vice President under Abraham
Lincoln and people are discussing a
tweet from the former presidential in
gubertual candidate Andrew Yang now
let's go see if we can find this [ __ ]
let's go see if we can find this tweet
oh it's this is something stupid that he
said I don't know Lincoln won the
presidency on a brand new Republican
ticket in 1860 with 69.8 percent in a
four-way race
he took a Democrat Andrew Johnson and
his running mate you are a [ __ ] idiot
you are such a [ __ ] idiot Andrew Yang
what a dumb [ __ ] do you not see
what's wrong with this tweet folks in
1864 and 1864 the Presidential nominee
did not select a running mate
got it the two offices were ran as
different elections we didn't do that
back then in 1864 the president the vice
president and the presidential election
were two separate elections
I think is that why is this what this is
that what this is
oh Jesus Christ
um someone's got
um a video here from the resistance
on let's see what this this does for
General Lee and the Confederates there'd
be no convictions and what happened next
Northern U.S congressmen don't want to
seat Confederates or their sympathizers
in Congress they want a union military
presence in the southern states to
maintain Law and Order and they want to
pass protections for Black America
but President Johnson vetoes those
protections and fires one of his
so-called radical cabinet members who
agrees with them
and as a result Johnson is the first
president to be impeached but he escapes
conviction in the Senate and so
reconstruction and Reconciliation are
compromised and crippled
statues of Robert E Lee and Jefferson
Davis are built to commemorate white
supremacy and treason and myths around
states rights and Southern Pride live on
as a transparent cover for the shame of
an ideology of extreme brutality and
delusional Supremacy and that culture of
the Confederacy rises again and again
anti-democratic anti-science anti-black
anti-brown anti-immigrant
anti-everything and anything that isn't
their Clan and Century after Century
so-called white moderates find
unscrupulous reasons to accommodate
these white supremacists for their own
self-interest for their lack of courage
in Black America Native America
everybody else be damned and so now we
see today rising from the boneyards of
America's unatoned sins Marjorie Taylor
green a terrorist sympathizer who
signaled approval for political
assassinations who disparages Jews and
Muslims who publicly harasses child
survivors of school shootings which she
claims are just conspiracies to steal
her guns who Republicans elected into
our Congress and Republican leadership
rewarded with a position on the
education and labor committee these
people are not only uninterested in
unity they openly Embrace political
violence this is not white privilege
it's our recurring white nightmare
haunting US Century after Century with
their suicidal fantasy that nobody
really belongs here but them
that's a pretty powerful video I'm glad
we went in that thread what do you guys
think I think that's a great video okay
now I'm gonna get out of the Andrew
Johnson thread here Kmart we already did
that we went through that uh Sweden and
Finland
some news on Sweden and Finland uh
Russia warned Sweden and Finland against
NATO membership and they're threatening
them Russia is threatening Sweden and
Finland
I bet they're terrified
um Sweden and Finland you know that are
trying to also join the alliance of NATO
uh rather that'll actually happen or not
it's it's very unclear at this point
rather that will happen but the Sweden
and NATO are basically giving Russia the
middle finger like [ __ ] you you can you
threaten us
threaten us okay well
good luck
good luck
so I mean in in
terms Sweden and Russia are telling our
Sweden and Finland are telling Russia to
go [ __ ] themselves
now Russia again is threatening them but
they're not heeding that that threat uh
John Oliver this is a good story let's
see I wanted um
our co-host take on this let's see if
he's
um
uh John Oliver on last week uh tonight
you guys know he does his show on HBO
and I can't play Clips I'm unfortunately
the reason why is because they'll make
me [ __ ] silence it on the YouTube
video
it's like they'll make me cut it because
HBO owns it and they don't want me to
play it in a copyright and all that
[ __ ]
and then I have to fight it so I can't
play it but
in the clip that everyone's talking
about
um which is this one here
uh so maybe I'll retweet this this clip
here and I'll retweet this
um what what basically um John Oliver's
talking about in in the uh
is trying to get Congress to pass laws
to make sure to protect our data is what
he's trying to do right uh so he does
this thing where he like they they
collect people's data and they run ads
against the people's data and then they
get people to click on the ads and
they're able to collect more data from
the ads that they clicked on
and uh he he has a little manila
envelope that may or may not it seems
like in the clip
have uh congress people's
um information in it
and what seems like blackmail because a
lot of people are saying is blackmail
what seems like blackmail he tells
Congress hey if you don't want these if
you don't want this the contents of this
envelope opened
and the people who may or may not be
Congress people inside the envelope to
be revealed
maybe what you should do is pass a law
to where I can't reveal it
to where I can't collect your data you
know he's kind of he's kind of goading
them into uh
into maybe challenging him
to pass legislation to make sure that he
can't release what's in this envelope
you see him holding up an envelope here
um so and John Oliver does a great piece
on this and again I wish I could show
the clip and I could show you here but
then they cut it off and when people
come back to re-watch this damn thing
they wouldn't it just wouldn't be
it just wouldn't work
wouldn't work because it would be
silenced that's what they do it's like
when I play something on YouTube
and the the copyright owner they say oh
that's that's our that's our that's our
material even though I'm reacting to it
right because there is like um
yeah there's the the
where I can react to it and [ __ ] like
that but you got to go through a whole
process with YouTube to get the video
going and sometimes they pull your video
down
it's a pain in the [ __ ] ass
it's a pain in the ass
so sometimes when we're watching videos
that I know that are going to be a
problem I can't play them here
blame me
blame the law maybe we should uh
Congress to change that too where we can
react to anything that we want it's our
freedom of speech um he also does a good
uh bit if you're gonna go to the John
Oliver thread and that's all you got to
do is just search John Oliver or go to
the the training thread and the trendy
Trends and the Tweety tweets
he's also got a good uh piece on oan
I know a lot of people have uh
have been following the story of oan and
how uh DirecTV dropped their ass I'm not
sure when that's effective the exact
date but soon the F uh it's a effective
soon that oan is basically going to lose
90 percent of their revenue it's going
to be gone poof they're going to be
wiped off the face of the Earth because
of capitalism they're gonna [ __ ] about
their freedom of speech oh capitalism
made us made us not we need socialism is
what we need we need socialism to make
sure that our fascist ideas get out
there
we don't want capitalism yeah he's [ __ ]
they don't know what kind of country
they live in they never have
okay let's go back to the trendy Trends
and Tweety tweets uh Herschel Walker is
a dumbass he's trending
so we'll get back to that let's see what
else is turning here I got Dr fauci was
trending wasn't he trending for a little
bit let's let's um let's let's
refresh here see if we got a new
a new list this stuff changes very
quickly some especially sometimes on a
Monday when news is dropping
it changes
With the Wind now Herschel Walker and
Tony Dungy
I don't see Dr fauci he was trending
maybe it was just the Russians who were
trying to get Dr fauci trending oh there
it is there it is here we go
here's the Dr fauji tape
um apparently uh Dr fauci here's ABC
News
Dr fauci told ABC news that Americans
should continue assessing risk for
themselves
as covid-19 cases tick up you know this
is the weird part
about all the [ __ ]
that all the lies that they were ever
told about covid
you tick back too far it's been two
[ __ ] years two years two years now
since we are on lockdown think about
that
think about that two years since we've
been on lockdown
and remember we were supposed to only
have like two cases and it would
magically go away
and here covid-19 is ticking up again
and remember when it was all it's going
to be gone by Easter it's two Easters
[ __ ] later and it's still not gone
Jesus Christ
morons let's listen to One found she
says let me ask you about the uh the
spike we've seen right here in
Washington uh you and I were both at the
Gridiron dinner this is a dinner that
had a about 600 or so uh attendees so
far I believe we're at 67 people that
have attested positive who are at the
dinner I'm told at least so far no
indication of anybody seriously ill uh
but but you know about 10 percent of
those in fact what what is the lesson
here should we not be holding events
like this or to the to the point we just
talked about is it time to accept that
we we can have an event like this but
there there's going to be a risk some
people will test positive if everybody's
vaccinated you know it won't necessarily
be that serious
I think it gets back to what we were
discussing just a moment ago John it's
going to be a person's decision about
the individual risk they're going to
take I think the people who run
functions who run big dinners who run
functions like the White House
correspondence ball oh thinking back the
grid eye and dinner are going to have to
make a determination looking at the CDC
guidelines and seeing where the trends
are I mean there are some places you go
not only is it required that you show
proof of vaccination but you have to
have a negative test the day you go to a
particular place yeah and I know a lot
of social functions throughout
Washington and in New York are doing the
same thing and it's up to the individual
to determine what their level of risk we
don't want to poo poo getting infected I
think people sometimes say well it's
okay to get infected no it's not because
there are things like long covid and
there are sometimes people even though
they don't require hospitalization John
they get significantly ill they may be
at home they may require a talk to
consultation but they don't get
hospitalized that's not something to poo
poo again each individual will have to
take their own determination of risk
so here we have Dr fauci you know saying
facts being reasonable
um and of course I'm sure the right wing
let's go take a look I'm sure the right
wing is losing their minds
something he's talking Dr foxy said
something
now what's Gary Larry say here you can
tell how much Fox News someone watches
by what they believe about fauci this it
must be wallowing in it the mar here
says Dr fauci has zero credibility he
lied to Congress about funding the Wuhan
lab and two years later still lying
about mask look this is really [ __ ]
dumb this is really [ __ ] stupid this
whole Mass thing mask mask work I had to
play a video
I don't know what was it last week or
week before
uh but Troy uh from Tic Tac
he had to explain to someone how a fart
works
and how The Masks work because if
artworks it's really stupid [ __ ]
listen The Masks don't just help you
protect from covid they help you protect
from all kinds of disease like the flu
like actually honestly during the flu
season a lot of schools if there's a flu
going around they should require
children to wear masks and the staff so
they don't spread disease around if you
can just put a simple [ __ ] piece of
cloth over your face this isn't hard to
[ __ ] understand
it really is not hard stuff
but they think it's a big huge
conspiracy in cabal that Dr fauci is
being reasonable and telling people to
use their own [ __ ] determination
because at this point most the people
who are going to be vaccinated are
vaccinated
be crazy
really [ __ ] crazy
really crazy okay I guess that's the
reason why Anthony fauci is trending
because he spoke he said something about
coronavirus I don't know okay let's see
what else do we got here
we are eight minutes into the second
hour you guys know every single weekday
we are here Live on YouTube Twitter
twitch and now from the Midas touch
Facebook page
so go follow us over on YouTube if
you're not already
make sure to subscribe to the YouTube
channel that way you can get in on the
Super Chat we got the super chat now
everyone knows over on YouTube with the
Super Chat is you can buy Super sticker
Super Chat support the show we much
appreciate that and everyone at if you
are a new listener maybe I should bring
this up we do a bone end of the week
poll every single week we've been
dropping it on Thursdays now so you
should go follow us at Tony Michaels pod
because we let you vote for bonehead of
the week that's another good reason why
you should subscribe to the YouTube
channel I put up uh last week's bonehead
of the week yesterday
it's just just the bonehead of the week
part just that part and if you missed it
and you want to just watch bonehead of
the week
I put it up yesterday Marjorie Taylor
green was our winner so go watch that go
to the YouTube channel subscribe and
re-watch the bonehead of the week if you
missed it
it's not a good reason to subscribe to
the YouTube channel and if you're
listening if you're listening to the
podcast don't worry we are in all the
directories even the most famously
boycotted ones Spotify Google Apple you
can find us there go download the pr
prior episodes get caught up a bit
if you're a new listener go get caught
up you can play those things in like a
time and a half time in three quarter
yeah it's down at the bottom you just
click the little thing that says how
fast you want to listen to it
and I know I already talk faster you
might want to listen to it like time and
a half time in three quarter but that'll
get you caught up faster and leave us a
review when you're over there on the the
directory of your choice the directory
of your choice
okay um mnuchin is trending now and my
four years let's go over and see what um
what this is a oh it has to do with
Jared Kushner well he would have guessed
oh
um
see one what's why is mnuchin trending
does anyone know
does anyone is is mnuchin part of this
deal with Jared Kushner axios
has two former top officials in the
Trump White House Jaren Kushner and
Steve mnuchin
they really did don't these two look
like
like serial killers come on
is it is it that cartoonish that Steve
mnuchin
and Jared Kushner look like evil
villains from the empire
unlike uh Star Wars I mean you know they
wouldn't be wearing a suit they'd be
wearing like you know the Empire uniform
but they certainly do look like evil
villains from like The Empire Strikes
Back or something right am I wrong here
or they you know they look like from a
movie or the serial killer movie right
like it's maybe like a father-son serial
killer type movie
I'm just saying it might be a good
summer flick if anyone wants to cast
them
Steve mnuchin's in the movies
that's what I hear
oh my God uh Steve mnuchin and and Jared
Kushner have secured billions with a
[ __ ] B of dollars from the Saudi
government
the Saudi Crown Prince is buying their
influence
with former Trump officials in the form
of investments in their new private
Equity Funds
the New York Times reports hmm
maybe maybe we should get some laptops
here I don't know I think I think we
should get some laptops from Jared
Kushner and Steve mnuchin it sounds like
sounds like Jared Kushner is not just
the one that got uh two billion dollars
you know a lot of people the other day
were like oh my God Elon Musk bought
nine percent of Twitter for three
billion holy [ __ ] that's a lot of money
I can't wait I can't wait for Elon Musk
to let Donald Trump back on Twitter
because 3 billion is the majority share
he's gonna be a board member and he's
gonna let Donald Trump back on Twitter
and blah blah blah blah blah
it's so much money three billion dollars
and this morning
and get reports here that Steve mnuchin
and Jared Kushner got billions of
dollars from the Saudi Crown Prince
probably probably hush money either that
or quid pro quo either way
they're getting they've done a dirty
money deal with the Saudi Prince
the [ __ ] Captain bones all over there
murdering reporters
murdering them and outright knowing that
everyone knowing that they murdered me
is like I didn't do it
and Trump says I didn't do it because
Trump's a [ __ ] liar
this is [ __ ] this is crazy ass [ __ ]
man
and and these [ __ ] are worried
worried about a laptop that Hunter by
known they're worried that Hunter Biden
sniffs cocaine off a hooker's ass
that really like that's their case
they're like oh my God it's so egregious
that Hunter Biden is a [ __ ] cokehead
and he sniffs Coke off a hooker's ass
it's ridiculous arrest him Joe Biden
can't be president because Hunter Biden
does cocaine and owns a laptop and he
sends [ __ ] emails
but Jared Kushner and Steve mnuchin do a
dirty money deal with a foreign
government
looking like they use their influence
that they gained
while they were they were government
officials
and now acting is what would seem to be
foreign agents
which they were always foreign agents
they all are all the trumpers all of
them I mean God damn they love Putin
they [ __ ] and love Putin
uh speaking of foreign agents someone
keeps talking about that in the chat
uh Dr Oz apparently has applied to be a
foreign agent
Dr Oz you know the guy who's running
ahead in the race in Pennsylvania for
the senate seat of Republican party I
I'm not scared
of Dr Oz becoming the candidate of the
Republican party in Pennsylvania like I
think that
like if you want to get a Democrat
elected in Pennsylvania
um
let's put that guy as the Republican
just like this [ __ ] idiot Herschel
Walker
Herschel Walker you see here in the
picture
he's a no-show
at the debate
at the Republican debate
for the senate seat in Georgia
now as you know
Senator Reverend Warnock
is in a special election seat
for the Senate
he won last year in the runoff
and we know that
now that
Judge Brown Jackson would not be
confirmed to the Supreme Court had uh
Warnock not one and alsoth not one those
runoff races and thank you Donald Trump
for absolutely destroying your base and
making sure that they didn't get out and
vote and thank you to Stacy Abrams a
special thanks to Stacy Abrams to
working her [ __ ] tits off down in
Georgia to make sure
to make sure that Democrats win and get
out the vote
and we should do the same goddamn thing
this year in the 2022 midterm all around
the country
all around the country same goddamn
thing
but here we have them in a runoff
they're trying to decide who the
Republican nominee is going to be
and uh Herschel Walker can't even show
up speaking and not showing up
MJ's here she says I'm out shopping with
my mom
the other birthday girl but I have to
give a shout out it's Kalyn said there
was love my way love you [ __ ] fan
I'll be back tomorrow MJ thank you so
much for the Super Chat and thank you
happy [ __ ] birthday MJ happy birthday
if you're still here and you're still
listening we love you here at the Tony
Michaels podcast MJ
Happy Birthday everyone wish happy
birthday to MJ in the chat don't fail us
write it out happy birthday go to
Twitter and follow MJ and give her a
happy birthday there as well let me let
me get her a handle here so you guys
know her
see you guys know our handle uh over on
Twitter you can give her give her a it's
it's Midas underscore MJ
um is her name but you can find her
handle at MJ
underscore Eris Aries 11 let me let me
hang on let me get it here I'll uh I'll
put it in the chat and everyone can go
there we go
all right everybody it's in the chat
there there is MJ's
there is MJ's handle over on Twitter so
if you're on Twitter if you have a
Twitter account please go over
and give a happy happy birthday to MJ
and MJ again
happy happy birthday to you MJ happy
birthday okay let's go back to the
Herschel Walker thing here
who
Herschel Walker
I want him to be the nominee what do you
think I'm excited about Herschel Walker
being the nominee in Georgia
abso [ __ ] lutely I think the reason
why Herschel Walker didn't show up in
the first place to um you know to debate
people which obviously he cannot do
but uh I think the reason why Herschel
Walker didn't show up in the first place
is it's a really long drive it's a long
drive from his house in Texas to Georgia
that's a long ways away folks
you can't just be picking up and going
you know
like that come on
you gotta you gotta you know sometimes
you gotta rest at home in your house in
Texas when you're trying to run for
Senate in Georgia just saying just
saying there's some let's go to video
because here's some good video of this
[ __ ] bonehead I mean he is a complete
utter bonehead just really stupid
I mean just it's it's baffling how
[ __ ] dumb this guy is sometimes let's
see
Ron has a video here
[Music]
um
oh well there's that Mitch McConnell
video maybe maybe we'll watch that uh he
says something about
um Herschel Walker here
um but there's a longer one this is it
this is it okay so we're gonna go back
to this video because I want to watch uh
Mitch McConnell say that Herschel Walker
is a good he's electable but um here is
uh Ron's got this thing here this is uh
hmm
I think this is
I think this is the Aaron's got here
this is the um
I think this is the the clip that
everyone's talking about this morning so
uh Raphael Warnock won this seat uh in
that runoff race against Kelly loffler
uh as you know back in uh 2022 early in
the year now this seat is one of the
most contested the top 10 list of the
most likely to flip in November tell us
what changed in the last 14 months since
Warnock won that seat
you know what what have changed where
did you start you know where do you
start at what has changed is uh you know
we've got an Administration that that
they're not leaders they're almost uh
they're they're waiting till they're
more reactive rather than proactive and
what I mean by that is you're one of the
first thing they did and I think people
need to know this is they decided that
they were going to give up our energy by
him going out giving up our energy now
we're not energy independent anymore
which started the whole downfall right
now gas prices is going out of the roof
you know right now you see if there's no
food on the shelf and I think people
need to know that and they're blaming
everyone else except themselves you know
I think they got to remember that the
song Michael Jackson said the man in the
mirror you got to look at yourself and
see what's going on you know this
country is the most you know this is one
of them okay again again I can't I can't
it's um it's it's hard to listen
it's hard to listen to Donald Trump's
word salad I mean it really is right I'm
gonna give Aaron credit here
um
this does this seem like a recent
this is from April 10th it's from
yesterday this doesn't seem like it's
from yesterday it feels like it has
Christmas [ __ ] in the background
oh God it just I can't handle Donald
Trump's word salad and I definitely
can't handle Herschel Walker's words out
so let's go
let's go to some more Robertson from a
turtle words out here
um this is an interview that Jonathan
Swann did with Mitch McConnell and I
guess he brings up Herschel Walker so
let's I guess let's listen to this let's
talk about the midterm elections and I
specifically want to discuss strategy
first you've talked about the importance
of having electable nominees what does
that mean to you
well what it means is if you look at
where the Senate majority will lie
and Georgia North Carolina Pennsylvania
New Hampshire Ohio Missouri Nevada
Arizona
almost all of those States
are competitive in November
and uh
we've had difficulty in the suburbs the
last few years
I'm looking for candidates who can
appeal to Suburban voters
and actually when in November
and so it's a value judgment you look at
the primary choices uh poll data
background appeal and um
we had we had a couple of Cycles where
the attitude was don't get involved in
primaries
so I always like to mention to people
for folks who may have forgotten Sharon
angle toddick and Richard Murdock
Christine O'Donnell the witch not a
witch sorry yeah I think it's pretty
safe to say after 2010 and 2012.
I concluded we need to change the
business model and by that I meant not
so much a philosophical litmus test
or in this era whether you do or don't
like Donald Trump
but can you appeal to a general election
audience
so your next question is going to be how
how are we doing and the primary season
is just beginning
and I'm pretty optimistic we're going to
have what I would consider a fully
electable nominee
in every one of those States
well you gave me four names
um
I have a few names for you
and I want to start with Eric Brighton's
a candidate Paul's indicate could be
your GOP nominee in Missouri right oh
this is a great one that Eric greitens
because if you go back and you look at
what Mitch McConnell is saying think
about what he's saying here folks
think about what the hell he's saying
right
Mitch McConnell is saying here we go
he's saying
that the the Suburban vote is they
they've really got banged up on the
Suburban boat the last few Cycles well
the reason why they got banged up on the
Suburban boat the last few Cycles is
because they had a [ __ ] grabber
a [ __ ] grabbing fascist
as their leader a liar a Cheeto dust
mobster Grandpa Poopypants the Suburban
people don't like that [ __ ] he
is a threat to their way of life
he is a threat to their way of life
doubt me on that
listen he's telling you out loud what
they're trying to do they don't want
Josh Mandel as their candidate they
don't want Eric greitens and they're
about to go through here as their
candidate in Missouri Josh Mandel in
Ohio they don't want Herschel Walker as
their candidate in Georgia because they
don't want Dr Oz the foreign agent now
we found out
as their [ __ ] agent or their as their
agent there you go as their nominee in
[ __ ] Pennsylvania
the reason why they don't want these
people as their [ __ ] candidates is
because they're endorsed by Trump and
they are trumpers
and they know that those candidates
don't do well in the suburbs because
they are Trump they are trumpism
and Suburbans don't want so bourbonites
don't want that [ __ ] Trump is a threat
to the Suburban people's way of life
it's a threat
it's a threat
let's continue said quote I want to tell
you directly Karl Rove and Mitch
McConnell hear me now you are disgusting
cowards and we are coming for you we are
no longer going to allow you not just to
attack me and my kids but to destroy
this country
it's just a sort of electability that
you're looking for later McConnell
so if you don't know the race if you
don't know what's happening in Missouri
uh with the Republican party let me give
you a quick I think we went over it on
the show and I'm gonna continue to bound
this drum as long as Eric greitens stays
in this race Eric greitens is the former
disgraced governor of Missouri
Eric greitens one as Governor uh in the
2020 or two excuse me 2016 election as a
trump style candidate
um it was soon found out that Eric
greitens was trying to Blackmail his
hairdresser
with naked photos that he took of her
when she came over to the house he duct
taped her to the treadmill in their
basement
and took pictures of her to blackmail
her
yeah
and he's he was a governor and he's a
Republican
I'm telling you this is the [ __ ]
truth the craziest part about it all
that's not all that's the salacious part
of it that he was that he was duct
taping his hairdresser naked to a
treadmill taking pictures of her so that
he could blackmail her later on
he was also stealing list and money from
his own [ __ ] veterans charity he was
defrauding people through a veterans
charity now in the state of Missouri
because he was governor he refused to
resign they basically they basically
traded criminal prosecutions for him to
resign in basic terms and it wasn't
Democrats or Mitch McConnell or anyone
like our Karl Rove that came after him
in Missouri when he was governor it was
the [ __ ] Republicans in the state of
Missouri
because he's a he's a piece of vile
piece of [ __ ] Eric greitens is
and it ain't no surprise that he's a
favorite on Steve bannon's Trader TV is
it is it a surprise no it's [ __ ] not
that that vile piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
Eric greitens is on Steve bannon's
[ __ ] traitor TV
now what has recently happened is Eric
greitens has decided it's a good idea to
get back into politics in the state of
Missouri so he's running for the senate
seat on the Republican ticket
which the Republicans are the one who
ousted him from being Governor not the
[ __ ] left we media and the Democrats
and all this nonsense that Eric greitens
wants to spew it's all [ __ ]
everyone knows it's [ __ ]
and recently Eric greitens ex-wife
Sheena
they're in a custody battle for their
children
has signed affidavits saying that Eric
greitens physically abused her and her
children
she signed affidavits in court
for a judge to decide if Eric greitens
should even be allowed to be around his
children
these are Republicans
whoosh
what Eric greitens has recently done is
tried to make has tried to sue Carl Rove
this is Beautiful by the way this is
[ __ ] beautiful by the way
Eric greitens the former disgrace Trump
style [ __ ]
governor
who had to resign because he
tied up duct taped his hairdresser to a
treadmill and took naked pictures of her
and stole money from a veterans charity
it's now running for the senate seat in
the state of Missouri in the Republican
primary him and his lawyer are accusing
Mitch McConnell and Karl Rove for his
plight that is the truth that's coming
out about him
through his wife's affidavits to try to
protect her children
from this [ __ ] what seems to be a
goddamn monster
I mean I wouldn't [ __ ] trust my kids
with some dude who duct taped his
hairdresser to a [ __ ] treadmill and
took naked pictures of her and planned
on blackmailing her really honestly I
wouldn't even [ __ ] let my children
around a republican at this point Jesus
Christ they want to marry children they
want a sexual life kids genders I don't
trust a [ __ ] Republican
as far as I could throw them [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I wouldn't let my kids around one
not alone [ __ ] that [ __ ] that especially
a trump Republican like Garrett greitens
I don't blame Sheena for wanting her
children to be safe
from that monster
don't take it from me go read the
[ __ ] story
go I'm telling you it's out there it's
out there the Eric greitens duct taping
and his hairdresser to a treadmill story
is out there because here's what
happened the Republicans in the state of
Missouri were terrified that this guy
was the [ __ ] governor
so they investigated him to try to oust
him
and they published the story they're
like here's the story here it is here's
what happened
I mean you can read the veterans charity
theft and fraud you can read that story
too
but if you don't think that these
Republicans are [ __ ] are are [ __ ]
monsters go read the goddamn Eric
greitens
duct tape sex story go read that [ __ ]
and you'll maybe start to think
otherwise but this is gonna be their
candidate in Missouri folks let's listen
to what [ __ ] Turtle turtleneck Mitch
McConnell has to say about Eric greitens
he's chuckling enough bullets here
yeah I don't have any comment about that
ah Mitch McConnell and Carl Rover are
going to do everything they can do in
their power to make sure Eric greitens
isn't the nominee here in Missouri and
let me tell you something us as
missourians that should be a clear
signal that Mitch McConnell and Carl
Rove know that not only can they not
count on Eric greitens being the United
States senator in the state of Missouri
but they can't count on him to be
[ __ ] sane
okay
and you heard you heard Mitch McConnell
just say that they want [ __ ]
candidates who are electable and
suburbia you think Suburban moms are
going to trust a [ __ ] that duct
taped his goddamn hairdresser to his
[ __ ] treadmill and his basement took
naked pictures of her to plan on
blackmailing her with
come on you [ __ ] break
I mean mind you this is a man accused of
tying a woman up blindfolding her no no
duct taping he [ __ ] duct taped her to
the treadmill taking nude photographs of
her for the purposes of blackmail then
coercing her into sexual acts did you
get electable I think the voters in the
Missouri primary will take all of that
into account
he thinks he thinks the Trump
Republicans who who [ __ ] voted for
Donald Trump the [ __ ] Grabber locker
room talk that's all locker room talk
and all the sexual allegations against
Trump that's all [ __ ] fake news Mitch
McConnell don't you know that all the
sexual assault allegations all the
allegations of sexual misconduct and
rape against Donald Trump that's all
[ __ ] fake news
he thinks that the [ __ ] the Trump
Republicans in Missouri are going to
take truth and facts into account when
they elect Eric greitens as their
nominee what a dumb [ __ ] you are
a stupid piece of [ __ ] Mitch McConnell
you really are you really don't get it
yet everyone thinks that this guy's some
kind of political [ __ ] genius and he
is a dumb [ __ ]
it's a lot to take into account because
I can tell you one thing I can tell you
one thing
that Mitch McConnell doesn't know about
Missouri Republicans they are willing to
let Eric greitens be the Republican
nominee in the state of Missouri they
certainly [ __ ] are and some of them
some of them out there are really really
[ __ ] excited about it
um let's talk about account that you
have talked about
um Herschel Walker the leading GOP
camera here's the Herschel Walker that
we've been waiting for you endorsed him
yet his ex-wife says he pointed a pistol
at her head and said I'm gonna blow your
effing brains out you know like everyone
does really I mean honestly you know
what who doesn't who does oh my God
who doesn't duct tape their hairdresser
to their [ __ ] treadmill and who
definitely doesn't hold their [ __ ]
pistol to their spouse's head and
threatened to [ __ ] kill him who
doesn't do that kind of stuff holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] and an ex-girlfriend has
accused him of threatening her life
why is he a suitable candidate
Erza Walker has addressed that issue
repeatedly
over the last 10 years oh really he's
addressed it
you mean like you went to jail for it
you mean like he served prison time over
it
is that what you mean
is that what you mean because I don't
think that's what you mean
uh I think he's it's a heck of an issue
well he had
I love I love Jonathan Swann who's like
look duct tape keeping women naked to a
treadmill and then also pointing a gun
at someone's head and threatening to
kill them those are heck of issues it's
not heck it's criminal they're [ __ ]
criminals what don't you [ __ ] come on
Swan get with it this is the problem
that we have with the [ __ ] media is
they don't sit here and yell and scream
into a microphone like I will and call
these [ __ ] criminals if
Herschel Walker is accused of holding a
gun to his wife's head and threatening
to [ __ ] kill her and blow her brains
out that's a crime
Eric greitens duct taped a woman to a
[ __ ] treadmill use used photos to
blackmail her to have sexual acts with
him that's a [ __ ] crime rather they
paid for those crimes or not they're
still [ __ ] crimes they're still
accused of those crimes and there's a
hell of a lot of evidence
that backs up that those crimes that
they committed actually [ __ ] happened
and here's Mitch McConnell willing to
capitulate to the fact that Missouri
Republican primary voters are likely to
[ __ ] select Eric greitens
that [ __ ] scumbag that Bannon style
Trump scumbag
as their [ __ ] nominee in the state of
Missouri
and let me tell you something when Eric
greitens if he does get elected in the
state of Missouri which I actually do
not think
that he will be the United States
senator from the state of Missouri I
hope he's the nominee for that reason
alone
but if he were hypothetically if that
[ __ ] scumbag was elected in the
state of Missouri as the senator here in
my great state of Missouri
as the Senator Mitch McConnell would
welcome that piece of [ __ ] with open
arms
he would love Eric greitens love him
love him some Eric greitens well he
would act like it he had had some
troubles just like he's acting like he
supports Herschel Walker pointing a gun
at his wife's head here this is in
recent years uh he's a hero in Georgia
uh almost every candidate has had
troubled periods I mean I don't know
that almost every candidate has pointed
look I don't want to argue with it I
think Walker is completely electable
he's actually ahead at the beginning of
this race and we're fully behind him
how did you absorbing those what does
that tell you
that Herschel Walker yeah I don't
believe that polls down in Georgia are
[ __ ] correct I think they're full of
[ __ ] [ __ ] to be honest with you
it's all [ __ ] that Herschel Walker
is ahead of Warnock give me a break are
you kidding me get out of here with that
[ __ ]
but that just because Herschel Walker is
ahead in the polls Mitch McConnell's
like oh that whole gun thing the whole
threatening someone's life thing with a
with a [ __ ] weapon and you know we're
gonna put that beside us because he's
ahead in the polls and he may win
uh Nancy here Nancy here is confused
about what we do here Nancy on Facebook
she's she I I think and Nancy I think
you need to go you know somewhere else
maybe to get your commentary uh she says
comment down and clean it up Tony
now Nancy that's not what we're gonna do
here that's not how we do it here uh
it's not it's I I take it this is not
your thing you said um I can only take
so much of this guy even though he's on
our side
you know this this is this is the crazy
[ __ ] that we get this is why I have to
show films like this with Jonathan Swann
talking to Mitch McConnell about [ __ ]
that really matters
you know what you know what really
matters is Senate races that's what
really matters and really putting it in
terms to make sure that the American
people understand the stakes here
Jonathan Swann acting like Herschel
Walker threatening the life with someone
with a [ __ ] loaded gun and Eric
greitens duct taping a woman naked to a
treadmill is just a problem in an
election that's not a [ __ ] problem in
the election folks the problem is is
that Republicans want these people in
power they want they want the person who
is duct taped a woman naked to a
treadmill in charge of your gas prices
they want they want Republicans who are
trying to marry children in Tennessee
and Missouri they want them in charge of
your economy
Nancy thinks that I'm off the rails that
I just need to calm it down a bit I just
need to calm down and let the fascists
take over
we do not need to know the truth
we do not need to be confronted by what
is actually happening and what they're
planning to do to our country
calm down Tony you're getting out of
hand
and you're you really need to clean it
up a bit because a few [ __ ] F words
here and there are really really
offending my being
let me tell you something about the
[ __ ] f word the f word is the least
of your [ __ ] worries if you let these
fascists the actual bad f word
take over our country
and bang up our democracy
they want to take your voice away from
you God doubt me doubt me that they
don't want to take your voice away from
you because when they're trying to marry
children in Tennessee their next step is
to take away your consent as parents to
let them marry your child
doubt me
here we have Mitch McConnell sitting
here with with Jonathan Swann who is who
is completely acting as if
Eric greitens the former governor of the
state of Missouri who had to resign
because he's a [ __ ] criminal because
he duct taped a woman to a [ __ ]
treadmill and blackmailed her so he
could do sexual acts to her
he stole money from a veterans charity
and he's Jonathan Swann with axios who
is a great journalist and does great
interviews
but it's absolutely downplaying the fact
that these things are crimes
and they're [ __ ] despicable in Vile
he's like oh this is probably this might
be a problem in this election uh Mitch
McConnell oh it might be a problem well
Nancy I'm not gonna calm down and
Jonathan Swann if he had any [ __ ]
balls and had the energy that I had to
go after Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell
wouldn't be acting as if it's completely
normal for Eric greitens or Herschel
Walker to be their [ __ ] nominees
so take it to the bank Nancy then I'm
not going to calm down I'm not going to
stop fighting for our democracy I'm not
going to stop fighting for your Liberty
and for them not to take away your
Liberty away from you
it is very [ __ ] important to me that
Nancy you have your Liberty and we as a
democracy protect it
everyone's Liberty every [ __ ] last
person who's here rather you're a
citizen
rather you're part of the lgbtq
community
rather you are black white brown rather
you are whether you are an immigrant and
a migrant
rather you are a refugee rather you're a
Christian Muslim a atheist I don't give
a flying [ __ ] your Liberty matters and
it matters here and our constitution is
supposed to protect it and they want to
tear up our Constitution and throw it in
the [ __ ] trash along with your vote
and along with your Liberty because they
want to tell you how to live what to do
who the [ __ ] who to love where where
your children can and can't be who they
can and can't marry and when and when
they can't get [ __ ] married and they
want they want it and they want it now
doubt me they see an opening with
trumpism
so no
no
I'm not gonna calm down
I'm not gonna quit saying the [ __ ] f
word
so if you don't like it you better go on
to your little capitulating news
someplace else you better go find media
someplace else
that is gonna kowtow to your
sensibilities
clutching
that I may use the [ __ ] f word get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] and
anyone who's quote unquote on our side
should know that if we're on our side
you're on the side of democracy
and come hell or high water my friends
are these fascists gonna take democracy
away from you
and I will yell and scream into the
microphone for two hours a day three
hours a day five days a week six seven
days a week if I [ __ ] have to
to get a word out there for people to
understand what is going on for people
to know what's at stake
it's more important now than ever and I
said it last week and I'll keep saying
it now is the time not tomorrow not next
week not [ __ ] next month now is the
time to fight the fight that they want
to fight
it's we cannot we cannot get distracted
by line items and bills that do not
exist
we cannot be distracted by people who
say oh just calm down it'll be okay our
our country is good don't worry about it
the 2022 midterms even though
Republicans win they won't take away
your Liberty shut the [ __ ] up yes they
are yes they will yes they're going to
if you give them ability if you give
them the ability
to take away your Liberty you goddamn
right they will
you God damn right they will they're
doing it in Texas they're doing in
Florida they're trying to marry children
in Tennessee and Missouri
Andrew Andrew Giuliani says in an
interview if he becomes the governor of
the state of New York he will pass a
don't say gay Bill ostracizing LGBT
community members from society they will
pass anti-trans bills they will make
sure to strip away Liberty from the
others and then they will comfort you
they will come for you
don't doubt me
I mean you can if you want to
you're completely welcoming you are well
within your rights and your Liberty
to doubt me and to doubt the truth
and lose your Liberty in the meantime
well guess what I don't care if you
doubt it
doesn't matter to me if you don't want
your Liberty it doesn't matter to me if
you think I'm out of control and I'm out
of line and it's ridiculous that I would
say these things and be this way I don't
give a [ __ ] doesn't matter to me I am
willing
to do and say just about anything on
this show to make sure that your Liberty
is protected
that your democracy is maintained
because here on this show on the Tony
Michaels podcast we are pro-democracy
full stop Hook Line Sinker a thousand
percent
we are pro-democracy
and we will not stop yelling and
screaming into the microphone even if
it's a few cuss words
we will go all out 100 all the way
and Beyond the 2022 midterms
because the next election after that is
just as important if not more important
than the one we just had
and the one we will have you think these
fascists are just gonna be like you know
what oh my God they beat us in 2020 and
then they beat us in 2022 so uh we're
just gonna give up and stop being
fascist
they're not gonna stop
they're not gonna they're not gonna be
like oh well you know that whole Nazi
thing that we tried in America that
didn't work so
we're just gonna you know go back to
doing what we were doing before
they've been trying to take over our
country for decades
and they're not gonna stop
they're not gonna quit so you can't
either
so you have to have strategic outrage
you have to
we have to have messaging we have to
continue to pound the drum to let people
know out there who aren't listening to
politics
that hey they're trying to marry your
children it's real
and they're more than just trying to
marry their children they're using the
bill to make it seem like they hate gay
people
and they hate gay marriage
just to marry your children
they're passing laws sexualizing your
kids gender in schools
they're passing laws
they're passing laws
to make sure to make sure
that transgender people are ostracized
from society because they don't like
them they're different
we ain't doing that here
we are not doing that here we're going
to keep going up here we're going to
take a quick break
we'll be right back
with more [ __ ]
and no more [ __ ] to give right after
this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
years Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[ __ ] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
oh Nancy
I hope you come back and you know
try to watch the show
try to realize
[Music]
why you should be just as outrageous not
more outraged than I am
about them stripping away your democracy
so that's what they're trying to do is
trying to take away your your democracy
your vote
that's what they're trying to do
okay let's go back to the Tweety tweets
and the trendy Trends here
what else is trending let's see let's
refresh let's refresh refresh refresh
everyone liked the uh the rant they just
went on
and liked it even Ken here he says Long
Live shady I don't know what that means
exactly I don't want to be saying I'm
throwing shade I don't know
I don't know I'm not sure if he's saying
I'm throwing Throwing Shade on Nancy I I
like Nancy I like a challenge folks I
like to be challenged sure you can
challenge me
absolutely you can challenge me you say
too many F words oh oh my God this guy
who has [ __ ] him written on his hat
says a lot of f word and of course the
gang is [ __ ] him on his hat
says the f word like all the time I
continually I'm not going to stop either
saying the f word it's gonna happen a
guy who has the word [ __ ] on his hat is
probably gonna say the word [ __ ] a
couple times
probably gonna happen thank you Ken
for the Super Chat thank you very much
well also if you guys want to support
the show remember we do have the super
super chat now you can also go to the
tonymichaels.com and if you want one of
these [ __ ] em hats you go to the
tonymichaels.com
go to the top of the page
in the in the merch store you can get
you a [ __ ] hat there's shirts
you can get you a fascism sucked shirt
fascism sucks it does it it sucks to
suck and fascism sucks
it really it sucks it sucks balls okay
uh let's see what else does so we have
Herschel Walker uh khashoggi is of
course trending we know that could show
you uh Jamal khashoggi was killed by the
crown bench murdered by the Crown Prince
and the Trump Administration and Trump
himself helped them cover it up
of course we know that and now Jared
Kushner is receiving uh two billion
dollars what seems like quick broke low
money hey who could have guessed too
good against
let's see what else do we have Ryan
Reynolds is trending uh that probably
has nothing to do with politics I could
probably make it about politics though
what do you think what do you think in
the chat do you think I can make the
Ryan Reynolds trending the trendy trend
of Ryan Reynolds you think I can make
that political you see now I did the K
marker there
you see I turned that into politics
foreign
I was trying to think the whole morning
I'm like Kmart politics how does that
work
and then I then I thought you know what
I I did not know that I did not know the
truth and when the truth was known I
believe that Kmart still existed
somewhere out there on a distant planet
let's see
what else is trending here
Kmart's still trending
I just want to make sure I'm touching
all bases here okay folks I don't want
to miss anything
there's a lot of stuff I'm sure I'm
missing out there people are yelling and
screaming about that I'm missing
I want to end on this uh we're 53
minutes into the final hour so we're
coming to a close here but I think uh I
want to finish up
um with the
story about the Kushner because it's
still trending it's way down at 29. see
this is the problem this is the problem
that we have that the Jared Kushner
story is trending at number 29 this is
[ __ ] ridiculous this should be like
the number one [ __ ] story at least at
least for five six seven eight days
right here we are here we are trying to
figure out what the Trump Administration
was doing the entire time what was their
motivation why were the children in the
White House you know the [ __ ] Trump
and idiots out there the MOG the maggots
the Maga fascists
the let's go Brandon Nazis are
completely obsessed with Hunter Biden's
laptop uh Fox News oan uh talk radio
can't stop talking about Hunter Biden's
laptop right there's got to be a
projection here there has to be
something there has to be something that
is [ __ ] the reason why we we can't
stop having a conversation about how the
president's degenerate son owned a
laptop
it is brutal like we're having this over
and over and over again
um here's mail here you go
here you go
see this is why I love Mayo's account
that's why I love you Mayo if you're out
there listening mail this is why we love
you
I'm asking questions right here and she
asked the appropriate question for me
and you know the answer you know the
[ __ ] answer
she this is not Mayo asking your opinion
it's a rhetorical question at best
who else thinks Jared Kushner sold
America's secrets
duh absolutely probably two billion
dollars worth of them what do you think
why do you think why do you I why do you
think the Cheeto dust mobster took boxes
of classified documents and top secret
documents and he stole [ __ ] from the
White House
he didn't take it because he was scared
he'd get charged with crimes he took it
because he wanted to sell it
that's the only thing that these [ __ ]
idiots can all continue to think about
is what can I sell how much money can I
make what's the quid pro quo what is it
where's the profit that's why they're
always talking about how Hunter Biden is
Hunter by Nat Joe Biden China and three
million dollars and all this [ __ ]
three million bucks okay so let's let's
evaluate this let's say let's just say
that Hunter Biden got three million
dollars from who who God knows who from
God knows where illegally right
let's just say that
what about Jared Kushner getting two
billion dollars right with a [ __ ] B
Now with an m a b it really makes me
think that when Donald Trump the Cheeto
dust mobster last week or the week
before whatever the [ __ ] that was you
lose track of time with these [ __ ]
idiots
when he was talking about how
oh Joe Biden received illegal money from
foreign governments
a dirty deal was done with his influence
of being the president or vice president
of the United States and his son
benefited financially from it
maybe maybe just maybe Donald Trump knew
that the story
about Jared Kushner receiving two
billion dollars from the Saudi Crown
Crown Prince
with the influence of Donald Trump being
president of the United States
maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
that has something to do with it
maybe it's a distraction projection
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
I'm sure that the Cheeto dust mobster
talking about some [ __ ] stupid ass
bogus ass story about Hunter Biden
receiving money from a mayor or some
[ __ ] from Russia
some [ __ ] thing that he read on a q
Anon thread
is a distraction
from the story that was going to drop
about Jared Kushner his son-in-law
and his daughter
receiving two billion dollars
from the Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia
the Saudi Crown Prince
oh projection I think I think I think we
should be looking at Jared kushner's
laptop I think we should be looking at
Don Junior's laptop I really think we
should focus on their emails emails
lock him up lock him up lock him up so
we will not we will not back down
we will not back down
from the fight
even though Nancy Nancy we're on your
side we're on your side and I'm frankly
I'm fighting I'm fighting a good fight
for you for your Liberty
with all the f words and all the
language that you hate
um someone keeps telling me to go to my
DMs
um and let's see
oh the voter suppression bills the 400
voters yes that's another thing that
we're trying to fight against because
they're trying to take away your vote
there is 400 suppression bills that
they're trying to pass
with about
[ __ ] voting machines that don't exist
like Mike Lindell he's gonna he's gonna
make sure there's no machines anywhere
ever
in the history of ever ever
but we're not gonna stop
We're not gonna stop there we're not
gonna quit talking about how they're
trying to take away your Liberty they're
trying to take away your vote because
they want to take away your democracy
that's what Putin is doing in Ukraine
Putin is killing innocent women and
committing war crimes in Ukraine because
democracy is his enemy
democracy is his enemy
that's what's happening
and it's not just it's not just
democracy here it's democracy around the
world because folks fascism
authoritarianism their mortal enemy is
democracy
and it's it's not the institution of it
it's the idea of it
when a human being has the idea of
freedom and liberty
they will choose that over autocracy
almost every single time
autonomy
is over autocracy they will choose that
and that's why Putin is murdering women
and children
and the Ukraine and committing war
crimes and frankly the same war crimes
that the fascists here in this country
are chomping at the bit to commit
against us so no I will not settle down
I will not calm down I will not stop
saying the F word
I will continue every day to be right
here on YouTube Twitter twitch two hours
every single weekday Monday through
Friday yelling and screaming trying to
protect our democracy trying to give you
the weapon of messaging to get out there
and spread amongst your community in
your schools
the attitude
show these people that we are not gonna
we are not gonna not fight we're gonna
fight for our democracy that is what
we're going to do we are going to vote
and we are going to do all the things
that come along with voting registering
people to vote talking about voting yes
we're going to try to protect the
mail-in ballots yes we're going to try
to protect voting machines we're going
to try to protect the Integrity of our
elections from Republicans who want to
steal our elections which the evidence
is clear now more than ever that that's
what they tried to do in 2020 was steal
our democracy by ripping up our
Constitution and wiping their asses with
it
and we on this show will not let that
happen so tune in every single weekday
Monday through Friday two hours YouTube
Twitter twitch just type in Tony
Michaels podcast or come visit us on the
Facebook page of Midas Touch where we
broadcast same time same place Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific and until tomorrow Surfs Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon